[Music]
the talent pipeline's really all about
taking a longer term approach to
recruitment rather than the traditional
one it's an approach that recognizes
that the goal is not simply about
filling vacancies the goal is about
having the right people in the right
posts and that's not a quick
win
it's about investing time and energy
into people upfront getting them ready
for positions before they become vacant
we're starting early with high quality
work experience and engagement with
schools and colleges we're creating
volunteering opportunities that are
non-committal and flexible we're
establishing apprenticeships as a key
Pathway to employment and progression
with an emphasis on growing our own
people and and we position our Council
as a go-to Organization for high quality
graduate placements with a graduate
scheme that will attract people Beyond
University with the talent pip line
we're building on an already successful
one team culture here at Northeast
arire if I were to put it simply we're
creating an environment where people can
be and want to be successful I'm David
Vickers I'm the current comms manager at
Northeast Abshire District Council um I
started here seven years ago as a
digital media officer and prior to that
I worked at bover District Council for
two years as a temporary technical
officer okay so I started off as I say
as a financial services apprentice and I
did my aat level two level three and
level four which made me a qualified aat
technician uh and now I've just started
SI first so that's the chartered
Institute of public Public Finance
accountancy to become a chartered
accountant so when I started at the
Northeast I had to become a casual
lifeguard and which abled me I had to do
my lifeguard
qualification as I wanted to develop up
through the ranks I developed uh swim
teaching I then went on to my business
management so that helped me become head
attendant and then obviously helped me
become duty officer I'm Rin Fern uh I
started last year as an apprentice
assistant account
I was working at level two and now I'm
level
three so when I first started at an EDC
I never thought that i' I'd ever become
where I am now I just thought I'd be a
vehicle mechanic and that was it but the
opportunities and the courses and the
progression that you can go through uh
and the training provided is basically
whatever you want that'll help your job
um so the main benefits of working here
for me personally um having a young
family at at home um means the
flexibility of working is just brilliant
be that the hours where I could come in
a little bit later if I need to drop my
doll off at school um or working from
home cuz you know we we tend to do
hybrid working here that means I get to
be at home see my family a little bit
more than I would if it were full five
days in the office and that that
personally for me is is brilliant um and
then in the job role itself the fact
that I feel like we're empowering the
residents and our businesses and I'm
giving back to the community I guess
through the role but just the fact that
it's a council that does care about its
presidents and we are really passionate
about our communities it's just really
really um I guess empowering you know
like you spend I don't know you work
colge eight hours a day with them spend
more time with your work College than
you do with my wife at home so you get
that friendship and you and because
you're always you're never on your own
in the Leisure Center you're always with
someone so you you bounce off them all
time and it just creates it's like just
nice friendly environment and obviously
you're always working with customers and
stuff like that so it is it is nice so I
would say if you're looking for an
apprenticeship it's definitely a
brilliant place to come to work um they
provide you with the support that you
need and they always say when you get a
job at the council you've got a job for
life and I do actually think that that
is very true um it's very supportive
place to work really nice people and I
could see myself working here for a
really long time well you get learning
opportunities in your day-to-day work
life and like answering the phones and
working in an office that's a lot of
learning um you also get the classroom
in the college and but I was also
recently given the chance to do a first
aid course which I think is a really
valuable skill for life in general as
well as at work any DDC staff are
fantastic um
anything uh any queries any problems
struggling with work there's always
somebody to help
you um as regards training they pay for
all the training plus you get paid as
well which is a
bonus um so yeah time at NC is brilliant
you'll never hear me ever say I Hae my
job so during my time studying my aat
level four um it was when the coid
pandemic hit so obviously we all had to
go to working from home and I was no
longer able to go to college to study um
but working here they gave me all of the
resources I need to be able to do that
from home uh as well as the support
needed and all of the equipment so I was
able to continue my studies without
interruption really um from home um
honestly could not recommend working for
Northeast abud Council enough um be that
at an entry level like I were when I
started here um or at a more senior
level that the support what is on offer
um the career progression and the fact
that you're empowered to make your own
decisions and they Embrace change as
well um the culture here is brilliant
the one team ethos that just runs
through top to bottom is just absolutely
brilliant um I would absolutely
recommend anybody to to apply for a job
[Music]
here